Chileans from many walks of life are
enlisting to combat the deadliest
wildfires in decades among them Jesus
Fernandes he's what they call a
brigadista a member of a firefighting
Brigade formed by Chile's forestry
Corporation who worked during Summers
the peak season for wildfires
despite the suffocating smoke he doesn't
wear a face mask he says it makes it
even harder to breathe
I have a degree in tourism but this job
teaches me other skills you never know
when you're going to need to know these
things so I'll do this as long as I can
it's dangerous work
there's an eerie noise hard to identify
at first but on closer inspection it's
the crackling sound of fire disguised by
Thick Smoke
the young brigadistas tell us they
receive only one week's worth of
training for this job
what have the fires taught you I asked
that they are increasing and becoming
far more extreme
[Music]
nearby other firefighters with just as
little formal training are battling the
Ferocious fires that are encircling this
entire area they belong to an indigenous
mapuche Community called lostokiwe and
have been working since yesterday to
prevent the fire from engulfing a
neighbor's home
they use pigs shovels and branches to
combat the fires that started
simultaneously in the forests above them
two weeks ago but they need more help
[Music]
the brigadistas arrived just in time
their leader calling for air support on
his walkie-talkie
there are three helicopters now being
used to try to douse the Flames that are
directed me in front of me but while
these are here in other parts here of
the araucania new fires are starting to
be lit and at least according to
authorities and they're just simply are
not the necessary resources
watches from her house
I have a lot of neighbors down there and
if they can't extinguish all this I
don't know what will happen
the plumes of smoke are everywhere but
for now it looks like yours home is safe
a victory against an enemy that after
three weeks of battles is showing no
sign of surrendering
Lucia Newman Al Jazeera Victoria Chile